[Music]
welcome to mastering the middlegame with
me
grandmaster been fine goal sort of a
misnomer now before we start I have to
Yellin to people at home I obviously
don't watch the other videos because you
know why would I do that
but I do read your comments because
they're so insightful they incite
violence and your comments were done
with unusual this week and that's saying
something so I'll give yourselves a pat
on the back so I watched my last video
and I was like moving around like this
and I was moving my hands because I'm a
magician and you guys didn't say nothing
you guys are like this is the greatest
video ever so I mean I know you're done
but like you know get smart or something
another thing you guys did wrong I do
the kids class on Sunday the kids class
is half an hour then there were
complaints that the video was half an
hour so your indolence is inefficacious
so come down in the club watch them live
like these fine Three Stooges jurors
kind of people here yeah because they
have a good jury okay now I was informed
by reading your brilliant comments that
the previous Grandmaster in residence
Josh freedo who I was rooming with until
two days ago said that Paul Morphy was
the worst and that's because he hasn't
met you at home or any of our audience
then he would know what the worst is
fact he claimed I believe that not only
would Grandmaster Ken West be more for
you to match but so it might be more fee
in a match but not blindfolded that's
crazy
okay now then Ben Simon stop crying okay
now to refute said you know nonsense
from Josh Friedel who said boy he would
not be a master today more of these
rings they would be over 2,700 and I
mean fidei okay not USCF but feed a okay
feed a over 2800 and of course you know
that I like more Felix showing more fee
games etc I like making fun I'm not sure
which is easier to do anyway so Paul
Morphy I've shown many of his games I'm
going to show two games I haven't shown
somehow black is at the bottom I blame
Ken West because it must have been on
the bottom for the last okay Flipboard
okay this is more fee versus meek and
you can see by his name that you you are
what you play he played a meek style so
you at home will be very proud okay so
this is called mastering the middle game
and I chose these two games because
they're very good middle games buy more
feet the first is a very strange French
because meek played and meek fashion
here he played g6 which nobody today
would play because it's terrible okay
and more if he played very strange in
the opening and I've seen him do this
before instead of putting the Knights on
f3 and C 3 he put them on e 2 and D 2
and then he bolstered his center with
his CNF pawn so very interesting way of
playing Bishop III 92 and Knight d2
that's really cool looking probably at
home you're getting your camera out to
take a picture of this position so all
wait okay good
get a picture of whites pieces why does
everything perfectly lined up in the
center and black is sort of playing like
me and Nakamura put together and me and
knock I want to put together that's
about as good as morphe that's but equal
okay so Bishop d7 castles and one of the
benefits of white not putting his
Knights on c3 and f3 which look a little
more logical is that we can defend our
Center pawns with c3 and f3 in this
particular instance we're not going to
play f3 because more if we play d5
blocking the bishop on g7 and blocking
the bishop on b7 and White's going to
later play either f4 9 f4 now let's go
back in this position where I've
actually had similar positions with
black because I like playing this
so-called hippopotamus interesting black
is meek and I play the hippopotamus
let's not look into that okay so it's
good thing they don't get that otherwise
it's are laughing at me so normally when
I'm black here I put my plums on d6
Knight d7 and my bishops have nice play
on the diag
and after the move defy v5 I'm not a big
fan of blacks bishops so because they're
not very active
okay so castles f4 f5 f5 is not really
the best move but at some point black
has to stop white from playing g4 f5
with initiative and probably a more
interesting move would be h5 because
after f5 black doesn't really have any
counter play black would like to use f5
for his Knight so actually by playing d5
and f5
I don't like any of blacks pieces I do
like the fact that he's blocking
everything up because in 1857 we didn't
see these positions now if we take a
random Grandmaster Josh freed L ok he
would say Oh more if he wasn't very good
ok and in this position it's very
difficult for someone like Morphy to
play a good plan because we didn't see
these positions in the 1850s we saw more
fee by move nine already checkmating his
opponent sacrificing several pieces
calculating to mate we didn't see these
block positions where he had to try to
unblock the position by playing the
right middle gameplan and when you have
a block centre like this there's
basically two plans for both sides white
wants to play either c4 or g4 and black
wants to play either c5 or g5 and
normally we determine how we're going to
play this based on where we have a space
advantage okay and would you say white
has a space advantage on the Kings side
of the Queen side okay
so White's pawn on e5 which I would call
the Kings side you would call it the
center because you're correct okay but
that's because you're in the center okay
and that's why you guys some of you both
I'm still going to play on the right
over here okay because that's sometimes
you get it you got to play the right
moves even even when they see wrong okay
so in this position since White's pawns
are on f4 and E 5 White's has a space
avenge on the Kings side and one of the
problem
with white playing on the queenside is
he's going to help blacks pieces if
white plays c4 and we trade do you take
c4 the bishop gets open the night gets
to go to d5 if we play g4 later I don't
see how that helps blacks pieces okay so
more if you played h3 I just explained
why you're still confused but that's
more of a you problem
okay hold on a second somebody just went
to get a drink I mean somebody at home
come on come back okay you're back okay
you don't go to the bathroom stay here
okay so black played 97 completing
development white play King age 2 very
calm ski ask ok
again more if he wants to play g4 but
first he may want to be able to move his
pieces to the Kings side ripped g1 maybe
get the other rook to the G file the
Queen and the King doesn't really belong
on g1 the King's very safe on h2 c5 even
the class will guess White's move here
let's call it a random student Alex
Marlar
no white will now be a lefty so what
would Y do c3 even Grandmaster Ken west
got it after you watched as his are your
video coming first
is it Chiron sir than me this video is
not going to be tabled and thrown in the
garbage
okay so you know sort of like okay so
well you got to do some work for once
you get paid by the hour right Ben oh
you guys man you're in trouble then okay
so white plates c3 and actually this is
where Star Wars was invented because
after c3 black was P owed alright one
person got it the Dennis Miller ratio
one-in-a-million okay now the reason
white plays c3 is he's solidifying his
Center black has no counter play I can't
tell you what black should do but black
shouldn't do what black did do okay
normally in these kinds of positions
Black's trying to put pressure on the
center since white has a beautiful
center well black already played f5 so
he's not going to play f6 which is good
because I would not recommend that
anyway and black doesn't have a lot of
pressure on d4 white as d4 defended
three times and it's attacked once so
now that the center is blocked and black
doesn't have counter play because of his
suspicious opening now more if you can
get to work I'm mastering the middle
game c4 this is the condom of a lower
rated player makes it attacked something
okay it's like Oh something happened
it's like something was said who they
get all excited right okay and it
doesn't make any sense but look how
interesting it is
okay so c4 Bishop to c2 and you can see
black was obviously playing on the right
because that's the right side for black
okay this ship c2 and now black really
doesn't have any counter play and the
center is blocked so now wife's really
going to attack on the kingside a6 some
sources say black played a5 this was
played 1857 don't ask me maybe Rex would
know because he might have been watching
the game I don't go well I'll ask Rex
next time I see him okay Knight f3 white
moves his pieces over to the Kings side
where he's going to execute black h6 boo
that move is quite meek right and you
shouldn't move pawns in front of your
king well you're going to get checkmated
there he should move his pawns backwards
if black could play h7 and f7 and Knight
f5 he'd only be clearly worse okay
and the reason h6 is bad is very obvious
it's because we're weakening the g6
square the pawn on h7 was defending g6
now we got a bishop on c2 we're going to
have a rook on g1 I got two other pieces
that might go to the G file I could play
Knight h4 so you really needed that pawn
on h7 and h6 applaud the decisive
mistake although some very strong player
like Kramnik or Carlsen would say black
was already lost I can't ask
or fee he was only 2100 strength what
does he know okay
so King age seven defending g6 rep g1
notice the build-up of whites pieces
whites night ISM the vicinity the king
is on the same diagonal as the bishop
the rook is on the G file and blacks the
bishops just can't do anything rook g8
Queen e1 knight c6 Knight age for every
white piece going towards the Kings side
and after the mistake Queen FA White has
a very simple sacrifice that wins Knight
takes g6 okay black has to take we play
double check got the rook goin we got
this goin
King edge seven losses to every legal
move f6 check Fe check probably the
computer would say Fe check is better
but so you play King f7 defending his e6
pawn he has an active King stance would
be proud f5 check okay this looks like
every game I played kokum outside an
hour ago this looks like Feingold Kokomo
every game okay
Queen h4 check f6 and unlike my usual
joke where white wins because of Connect
four he has Connect 5 so I have no joke
I've never seen connect 5 I'm so
confused
okay so White's down a piece but black
should resign but people didn't resign
back then so we saw lots of funny end to
the game this ship takes f6 giving the
piece back getting rid of White's great
pawns bishop g6 Bishop f5 check if the
King goes to c7 Bishop f4 wins Queen f4
wins Queen g3 wins Bishop h6 g7 and now
if I was black I would Castle hoping my
opponent has a heart attack it's the
most illegal move I can find instead
black played 9 g8 and then resigned and
according to one of the engines reports
I got white has something like 9
from eight in threes almost every legal
move is meet in three okay and I'm
guessing after Bishop d7 check I
wouldn't want to have black but many
other moves are made like Bishop g6
check and I it said almost every move
was made in three so that was that we
niche five is made in three okay
obviously these aren't doing so good
over here so that was actually a
brilliant game by morphe because they
had a totally blocked center and he
found the right plan of playing g4 first
he played c3 defending the center we
treated his Bishop and it was a very
slow build-up most low rated players
like to play as quickly as possible
sacrifice on move one might come ER and
played too aggressively and not build
and use all of their pieces morphe used
all of his pieces every game he taught
us to do that and if you watched my
lecture from a couple of days ago which
I saw Ben Simon put up today I had a
game that I played in Atlanta a few
weeks ago and i checkmated my opponent
and I also used all my pieces because I
learned from morphe and generally when
I'm trying to improve my chess I find
somebody about 2100 nice to tell you
their games and then I get really good
oh wait you forgot that that was sarcasm
okay yeah sorry I forgot who my
audiences okay now the next game I like
even more I save the best for last
okay sort of like he'll he'll you know
he'll show something he'll get huge huge
okay
ah I resign what did you do Ben Simon I
know I know I'm half kidding okay now
the next game was in a blindfold Simon
the reason Wharf he gave blindfold
Simon's is very simple almost everybody
I know rated around 2100 they give
blindfold Simon's that's all they ever
do right every Twitter play you know
gives blindfold Simoes and plays
perfectly they all do right and when
they're not given blindfold Simoes they
play even better than perfect it's just
amazing okay and this was played in
Paris more if he was given Simon's
against the
as players in the world and he was like
he got anybody better and they were
taking so long
they didn't have [ __ ] back then he
would actually go to Starbucks between
moves and he was it was like you know
come on man let's go okay so more fees
why he 45 and his opponent played the
Philidor which was very common in the
1800's d4 and when I play the fluid or
'the black which is pretty rare I'm not
the expert like ken west
when's the Philidor a lot I play d6 on
move one and I play e5 on move three all
right
so tanks and you could take with the
knight or the Queen and taking where the
Queen is actually more interesting and
that's what he did Knight c6 Bishop to
b5 in fact I was making fun of Kokomo
earlier because it's so easy to do and I
actually had a game with Kokomo today
and a double King pawn opening where my
queen was on d4 he played knight c6 and
I played Bishop b5 pinning his knight
and actually in a similar position
Kokomo we did trade and I won almost as
quickly as more fee but not not quite
okay Bishop g5 and the point of Bishop
g5 is actually quite funny it doesn't
seem like black would wanna play Knight
f6 or 97 and pinhas Oh Knight the
logical move Bishop e7 hangs the g7 pawn
so that makes it less logical of course
knowing what I know I think I would play
something like 97 here which I don't
want to play because I want to play like
Knight f6 and Bishop e7 so Bishop g5
shows that more if he was thinking early
a lot of players maybe some of the
audience just develop their pieces
looking around castle seeing if
Starbucks is open and then after they
develop their pieces they start thinking
so Y could play Knight c3 here black
would play Knight f6 and then they would
just play normal chess here if black
plays Knight f6 he's going to have some
bad pawn structure so he played the move
f6 Oh terrible and more if you saw the
bishop was attacked Knight h6
Knight c3 Bishop e7 short Castle you
surely when they take with a queen they
play a long castle but sometimes they're
playing g4 h4 and playing for mate it's
hard to play h4 yeah you have to take
your own bishop it's terrible
now the reason more if he's not playing
long castle and g4 and H form playing
for me other than the fact that it's
illegal
is that black made a concession black
did something bad black played f6
weakening which Square that's a little
too hard for this class E six and more
fees like oh you weakened east six and
you got this week diagonal here I don't
have to check me you I can just win
positionally okay just like a typical
2100 strength player winning all kinds
of different ways okay so you just short
castled
Queen c4 check not to play check but he
wants to get his Knight to e6 okay and
obviously Knight g5 is too risky so he
played Queen c4 check and then he played
the obvious Knight to d4 because he
wants to play 96 also Knights a c6
winning upon it isn't bad not so bad
okay and that's the problem with playing
f6 is you can't put the pawn back on f7
unless you cheat cheating wasn't very
popular in 1858 Queen to d7 rook to d1
Morphy always uses all of his pieces
these pieces are out he puts his rook
opposite his opponent's Queen a typical
idea rook f7 trying to get as other look
into the game f4 f4 is another common IV
and E for openings Sicilian double King
pawn because the nice line on f3 anymore
and we can gain more space if white does
play f5 and 96 which famous game played
60 years later does this remind you of
Alex Marlar if white plays f5 and 96
what game does that remind you of played
about 60 years later
you're not aware of Laster kappa blanka
come on man and the exchange ruie where
he gets 600 k so f4 was played a 5 that
makes a lot of sense
again more fees opponents don't have a
lot of counter play more view is known
as the sec set made kind of player but
he played a lot of games we just
outplayed his opponent his opponent
couldn't move and then they crumbled now
I said it before but it was like 20
minutes ago so you've all forgotten this
was a blindfold Simon ok because as I
said earlier lots of 21 hundreds give
blindfold sandals it happens all the
time we would 2100 right here
you give blindfold Simoes every once or
twice a week right yeah and you play
just like this ok I remember a blindfold
sign will you you were at you were
involved in a way to man you weren't
giving this honorable oh wait never
never mind
yeah ok so f5 and now black has really
good pieces except for one thing
black doesn't have really good pieces ok
White's getting a space advantage he's
moving up up up because black played the
move f6
and not only weakens the e6 square which
I've said a few times the bishop on e7
if not the best bishop I think it's the
second best bishop like this is one and
then this is two okay f5 rook goes back
to F a 96 rip goes to G a a for a force
probably my favorite move of the game
he's playing a blindfold sign wall and
instead of playing for mate with like
rook d3 rook h3 or something involving
g4 g5 you know a for stopping counter
play at my pulsons looks Wan ok after a
four black can't really move anything
maybe black could have played b5 if you
didn't do that ok
Knight g4 going to e5 Queen e2 and it
went to e5 Bishop g3 and he takes the
knight Black's only good piece and this
is a really good example of two knights
really crushed
to bishops takes work f3 rook h3 now you
all see the threat rib takes h7 so h6
Queen d2 threatening rook takes h6 which
leads to mate right Canwest and
threatening Queen takes Bishop winning a
bishop and thread in Queens x h6 now
notice more if you didn't play Queen e3
with the same age six threats because
then you're not threatening the bishop
on d7 so even though the blindfold sign
will morph you saw like good patterns
around the board
okay black doesn't want to get
checkmated into so King age 7
yum yum yum yum yum okay and this is a
really funny part of the game because
almost any 2100 player especially low
rated players would trade Queens and win
a piece up obviously White's King is
much safer than blacks King so you don't
trade Queens you check nature upon it
rook takes h6 check he also could have
played Queen f7 and tried to mate that
way is he playing it safe because he's
playing a blindfold sine wall no he sees
to me pawn takes is obviously illegal so
King takes again Queen f7 seems pretty
obvious to play queen g6 mate what would
black do if white played Queen f7 Queen
EA so Morphy instead played rogue to d3
see if I was blindfold I wouldn't be
sacking a rook and sacking my queen I'm
a piece of for nothing because what if I
don't know where something is oh that's
not me I'm done a lot of pieces okay but
he knows where things are more if he was
playing blindfold chess when he was 9 so
he pretty experienced it playing
blindfold
okay so Ricky's three mate is very easy
to stop ken west will give all the ways
to stop it
the silence is deafening anything can
you stop me Rick King age five attack
okay well quit Queenie AI with the edge
of Queen h5 but but if I trade Queens
you can't take back and the truth hurts
alright so King age five check and he
resigned why what's that what's the
problem what only only Rick g3 yeah
and King H one and beat be three solid
right so again more fee always used all
of his pieces when he attacked even when
he didn't okay remember what what Fast
Eddie Felson said I'm the best and if
you beat me I'm still the best okay
right you hear me talk it over there all
right now black he was really well
protected on the Queen side you got to
give him that the boy I couldn't do
nothing over there okay
the King was a little different so that
was a brilliant positional game a
brilliant strategical game followed by
winning material with an easily winning
game but he didn't want my lecture to go
too long so he made it the guy pretty
quickly if he had taken on CA I would be
like and now he has an extra piece and
he's advancing his majority on the Kings
side but instead he just checked me in
his opponent and here black resigned I
think one of the sources gave this as
the final of the game that's pretty cool
right will say the game ended that way
okay because it actually may have you
know 1858 eighty simultaneous some of
those notation sheets work good the men
wise were just weren't working then
which is funny because the game was
played in Paris so they could really get
the French going but they just couldn't
you know they were like manhua c'est pas
ball and crab it like wasn't that the
internet wasn't working that day right
no really it wasn't I'm serious there
was no internet that day it was out and
said come back in 130 years and we'll
fix it right and you know what happened
in 130 years Al Gore invented the
internet right all right I hope you like
this revenge refutation video of Donnell
I mean of Josh free Del's Wharf he
wasn't very good Morphy was the best
Morphy the greatest player who ever
lived
except for my fine well wait a minute I
mean you find people at home and oh now
I'll be making videos for the next
couple of weeks some of you guys are
confused at home shocking you guys are
like where's Ben Feingold
where's of arico be aware like in our
homes okay we're we're not here at the
Chess Club 24 hours a day that's that's
like Ben Symons job okay we have lives
outside the Chess Club so you could
actually call the Chess Club get a very
confused employee and ask who the
resident GM is and they'll say what's a
resident GM okay but they might tell you
the right answer you could ask for a
supervisor
okay then you'll really get in trouble
all right so when there's a resident GM
they make the videos we don't have like
20 guys sitting around it's not like
Grand Master Feingold and Grand Master
Ken Westar here every day you guys are
just lucky all right thanks for coming
to the lecture see y'all on Thursday
[Music]